let's welcome dave reuben
[Applause]
wow
i gotta tell you
i have never got an intro like that
before
pastor rob holy cow all right we'll talk
a little bit
in a few minutes guys look first off i
just want to say how proud i am to be
here with hundreds if not thousands of
you guys right now to elect larry elder
to be the next governor
of crazy california okay
because i know that every single person
standing here right now has a friend or
a relative that has left the state
california had its first loss of
population ever last year ever okay
people are fleeing we are the last sane
ones it's up to us
it is up to us
and it's hot and you came out to
thousand oaks to stand in a parking lot
while it's about 100 degrees i'm wearing
a sports jacket and you know what guys
you know what no matter how much anyone
here is sweating no matter how much
you're sweating right now
nobody is sweating like gavin newsom
right this very
[Applause]
gavin newsom is an evil disney cartoon
villain
okay he's gotta go he can go to french
laundry he can go to his vineyard but
he's gotta go
he's gotta go he's kept us locked down
he's kept us out of work he closed
restaurants all of the stuff you all
know it that's why you're here and i can
tell you guys i have a whole bunch of
friends i got hollywood friends politics
friends that have left and i said i'm
sure many of you know this i said to my
friend michael knowles from the daily
wire i will stay to fight for this state
i will stay
[Applause]
and we just need someone that can do it
we need someone that can do it and you
know who it is it's larry elder there is
just no doubt about it
[Applause]
they say one more thing and i know you
want to get to that i'm going to bring
up scafeo in just a sec but i
i want to say one more thing which is
that the meme out there and gavin newsom
is tweeting this and he's bringing in
his spectacularly loved uh surrogates
like elizabeth warren and amy klobuchar
yeah
[Applause]
but the meme
yeah i know he brought in a fake native
american from boston to tell us how we
should live okay
but the meme is that this is a
republican recall they keep saying this
is a republican recall
and i have no doubt that there are
republicans in this crowd right now
there are democrats there are
libertarians there are liberals who have
been mugged by reality there are good
decent americans here and this is what
we can do to create the biggest widest
tent ever and as they always say as
california goes so goes the nation
well how about we do it the way they
don't like that is my message to you get
out and vote vote in person they're
gonna pull their tricks vote on
september 14th the fight has just begun
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell